hello everyone I'm back to my hometown
and we are continuing the coverage of
the st. Louis rapid and blitz tournament
it's 11 Arnon versus you young ye the
first day of the blitz so this is a
blitz game and it's really a game that
will make you feel better about all the
games that you play after you see it so
without further ado let's just check it
out 11 with the white pieces opens with
c4 we have the English opening with c6
sorry not to d4 obviously a c4 and
English opening we have c6 Knight to f3
d5 now with III and the Knight to f6
we have d4 now comes g6 and now nice to
see 3 is the main line here but we have
B 4 by 11 Bishop to g7 you could also
try maybe something like e 5 to open up
an attack against the b4 pawn here and
deliver it with check but then you could
get something like D captures on e5 and
after Bishop captures on b4 with check
let's say Bishop blocks you trade here
captures captures and then after Knight
to e4 it seems like it's a it's it's
doing something but L let's say you go
Bishop Queen before you prevent castling
but then just queen e7 and the black is
perfectly fine here so you could do it
but it's a forcing line and well black
decided not to do it
so instead after Bishop to g4 young he
just continues development with Bishop
to g7 and now comes Bishop to b2 sorry
Bishop to b2 we have castles and now
Knight B to d2 11 continuous development
with a5 attacking the developed pawn
chain here and now just be five
advancing the pawn and now a for
preventing white from pushing a four but
also may be preparing Queen to FSI 5 at
some ideas but also rook to a f5 as you
see in the game and here we have rook to
c1 if one should play the one game such
as this one in 2010 against boo and he
want a very nice game but the game
continued differently with Bishop the f5
by you young G and now Bishop there are
two games in the database were short a
story was played but your Bishop to e2
is a new move by 11 and it is
basically as of this moment that we have
a completely new game so d captures on
c4 with Bishop captures on c4 and now C
captures on b5 and now Bishop captures
on b5 we have Queen to b6 which is a
very nice idea as 11th King is still in
the center of the board you are
attacking the light square bishop here
the light square bishop cannot move as
you lose the dark square bishop here so
we need to you have to defend we have
Queen te - and now the move we discussed
rook to a5 just piling up on that Bishop
on b5 and the only way to defend this
rook sorry not that rope the c5 the
bishop is now nicely defended but the
rook seems a bit misplaced here and the
Queen isn't all the great Ernie - so
Knight bt7 attacking the rook and you
could try something like Bishop
characters on b7 here but it doesn't
really work for example if bunch of
characters on b7 first you get rook
captures on d5 and then after the pawn
captures rule D captors on c5 you lose
the bishop on BT just Queen captures on
b2 so instead after Knight bt7
with nice the C for now Levin gets an
attack on the rook and the Queen and
well the Queen is much more important
than the rook so you do have to move the
Queen with Queen to d8 and here not
capturing on a5 right away first Levin
goes for rook captures on Fi and F 5 and
okay will G captures on f5 and now again
not capturing right away if you play
Knight captures on a5 it is possible but
then after Queen captures on a5 you get
nice the d2 just blocking and the game
continues like this we have a different
idea lemon first place Bishop captures
on b7 we have Knight captures on b7 and
now Knight captures on 85 Queen captures
on a5 with Czech and Queen to d2
so Levin prefer this idea he wanted to
trade queens that go into an endgame
where he would have a one point against
two points on the Queen side but he
likes his chances the bishops are of the
same color and the blacks dark square
Bishop is somewhat locked in in the
position but here young he decided that
he will not allow iron on the castle and
that he does not want to trade Queens so
here we have Queen to b5
preventing castles we have Quinta ytube
level now offers a queen trade one again
once again and Queen to b4 with Czech
Queen to d2 and now Queen the c4 with
check again preventing castles and
threatening to capture inators you can
if you now block with the Queen Queen a
to you you're gonna lose the a to pawn
the problem is you can't really save the
point if you play pawn to a3 this saves
the pawn but then rook c8 wins the game
as White doesn't have a good move here
you can't move your queen anywhere
blacks control of the CC file is
completely dominating you can never
castle
you could try you could try a queen to
e2 now but if you try Queen - E - now
you just lose a piece for example you
can just capture on e - and after the
King captures delivered roof to see to
check and now you just pick up the
bishop so that's not gonna happen so
it's not possible to play a three here
11 went Queen to c3 again offer the
Queen trade but now jung-hee just
captures the pawn we have Queen captures
on a2 and now all of a sudden youngji
has a very strong passport and a4 that's
ready to be pushed so 11 takes is this
opportunity to Castle kingside as soon
as possible with castles and now nice to
b6 getting the knight into the game
we've looked a 1 pushing the Queen back
and now Queen the c4 now young he wants
the trade and indeed if Queen captures
Knight captures attacks the bishop you
have to move it - then comes Rock a8 and
now you start pushing the pass pawn it's
a very dangerous position for white so
after Queen to c4 with Queen to a5 and
now Queen to b3 defending the knight and
attacking the bishop on beat you with
Queen captures on f5 and here with east
6 by black also is possible just the
Queen captures on b2 which will be met
with look to be one after the Queen
moves you're just gonna pick up the
night so black doesn't like this first
just east six trying to get the Queen
away from there then you're gonna
capture on b2 if the Queen ever leaves
this diagonal which the Queen doesn't we
have Queen back to be 1 by 11 and now
comes Knight to c4 threatening to
capture the bishop here black will be up
is this if this is possible so what do
you play here with white there really is
no good way good move here with white
for example if 95 if it's threatened
mate
I would Queen captures in age 7 just f5
the mate is prevented and now you could
try Knight captures here and yes you
will get a rook for two pieces but it
doesn't really do you all that much or
you don't even have to do it you can
play rook f6 and now you can either
capture night you can capture the bishop
here it's just a very nice position for
black so after Knights the c4 you could
try a roof to a to defending the bishop
but then you get a three and again
you're lost if you capture you lose the
rook and I just captures it and if you
move the bishop you lose the Queen and
b1 so here 1111 for the lack of a better
move played Bishop the c1 he just moved
the bishop out of the way and yeah it
now seems that everything works he
offers a queen trade but you know
everything doesn't really work here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this mysterious idea that the black
has in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it
congratulations you have just found a
mate in two and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
Queen d1 check this is uh just over this
is game over the white has only one move
that's ninety one and Queen captures
only one this is checkmate
but you young he misses this idea after
Bishop to c1 and he plays Queen captures
and b1 which is really interesting
because I move prior to this one we said
that the White has no good moves
and if 11 played any other move you
young you would have probably won the
game on the spot but here Levin played
the move that loses the quickest so
black has a mating - and young he
doesn't see it so sometimes you know
things like this can happen even between
super grandmasters so with queen capture
some b1 young he traded Queens we have
rook captures and now he prepares to
push his passport
it's okay maybe he saw this maybe he saw
that this was winning and then he
decided not to look any further
we have rook captures on be 7 by 11 a3
look back to b1 a2 and now look to
anyone's okay for the moment 11th rook
is stuck
guarding da to pawn so let's see what
happens with
'if I've black really wants to open up
the center and free his dark squared
bishop the bot 11 just ignores him King
to f1 now lemon starts to bring his King
into the game with eek after sandy for
he captures on d4 and now Knight to b6
just getting the night into the game you
want to play Knight to d5 Knight b3
night c2 from c2 the night attacks the
rook on a1 and if black can do this then
it's game over
but 11 of course will not allow that
King g-tube with Knight to d5 and now
Bishop to d2 preventing Knight to c3 or
B 4 so rook to a3 by young e
and now keep the d1 with rook to a for
going after the pawn but now just king
c2 no longer is it important as if you
move the rook you're going to lose the a
2 point but here it's important to
mention that both of them were very low
on the clock I believe both of them were
below 10 minute 10 seconds so here we
have Bishop captures grabbing the pawn
with Knight captures rook captures and
now rook captures on a2 so 11 is now up
upon which is a very interesting s he
was completely lost young he had made
him do but okay rook c4 check with King
D 3 and now rook to g4 going after the
pawns here we've looked a five
threatening the night and now Knight a
fourth check with Bishop captures rook
captures and now f3 preventing the rook
from capturing the pawn and now it's 3
to 2
this was perfect play this is a draw but
it's a blitz game of a both players have
a few seconds on the clock
so anything can happen we've looked to
be four by black and now rube g5 check
King to f8 and now kink the III the king
will now try to support the points with
h6 rook to g4 and now look back to be 2
trying to grab the points from behind we
have King to f4 well if the white rook
moves with rook to b5 now sorry we'll
look the b5 now and here comes King to
g3
rook to a5 and now King to h4 we've
looked the b5 waiting black has to wait
for white to push with rook to e4 and
now King back to g7 with g3 rook the b2
and now King to h3 still guarding the
pawn we've looked after now at
in the f3 pawn and rook to g4 check King
to h7 and rook F for defending and
attacking the f7 pawn king back to g6
defending the pawn and now g4 going for
King g3 drew cool movie will start
pushing your F pawn with rook to a 2 and
now comes king g3 look back to a1 and
now h4 with rook the g1 check King to f2
attacking the rook and now route back to
a-1 with h5 check King to g7 and now
rook to f5 making room for the king to
enter the game
Ruka do check King g3 and now rook to a3
now both players still with only a few
seconds on the clock I think at some
point they even reached a second on the
clock then they get get their increments
so it's you know possible to play this
rook to e5 and now rook to b3
we have came to f4 now preparing to push
g5 rook to a3 and now first rook to e3
in defending the f3 pawn rook a4 check
King to f5 and now rook a5 check and
here 11 blocks rook c5 we look back the
a3 attacking the f3 point and now
finally f4 with rook to f3 and here
rookie do you want to play rogue g1 so
you can push your g4 pawn although it's
questionable how if this is even
possible
I mean to push for more than a draw it's
always possible to push what will you
know come out that's for your opponent
to decide
we've looked back to f1 and now rook g2
we have looked at three and now g5 h
capture screen captures and now look
back to f1 and here h6 check with Quinta
h7 and now f5 so keeping keeping the
ponds near you wanna try and play King
f6 grabbed upon here if possible if the
black in black moves the rook and black
has to move the rook if he's to keep it
raw we have Roop to a-1 now comes King
to f6 and now rook the a6 check allowing
White's to capture the f7 pawn we have
King captures on f7 and now a very
interesting position you are not allowed
to capture the point if you capture a
pawn for example King captures on h6
you get rook captures on g6 with check
reconnecting and after the rooks are
traded the Jeep on will just Queen
without a problem and another thing you
also can remember it could be something
that happens in your own games if you
get this position where rook captures on
h6 then again you're lost due to f6 and
now you you will not be able to untangle
for example if rook h3 you try to get
the roof to the other side
rook e to now comes King to h6 King to
e7 preparing to pull the point now Luke
a3 preparing to deliver checks f7 now
comes Luke to a7 check King to f8 and
now King to g6 and here is why white
wins this King g8 and now whatever you
play you either Queen the pawn if
checked then you block with rook to e8
and then Queen the pawn and of course if
you capture then it's just rooms you
want check you have to keep an eye on
the rook rook F to check King moves and
now you just grab the rook and now you
of course win by easily checkmating the
black ink so after King captures on f7
rook the a7 check by you young G with
King to have six and now look to a6
check with came to g5 and only now real
captures on h6 worldwide has no more
tricks left we looked at ito and now
comes looked a six
we have rook to e7 check and now comes
King to g8 and here with f6 and the rook
to e1 and it was in this position that
players agree to a draw as this is a
well known draw an endgame where white
will not be able to put upon any further
as black can always just continue
checking the White King and you will not
be able to both keep an eye on the F
pawn and also block the checks from from
the black rook for example if you push
f7 and king a face will be seven and now
whenever you try to bring your king
closer the black rook will just keep
checking you and any other line will
also be will also end in a draw so yeah
after look to a-1 the game ended in a
draw which is very interesting I think
before the tournament they asked the
players which is your favorite kind of
win and I think xi said I'm not sure if
it was 11 but I think LaVon said that
his favorite kind of win is the one
where he's a life completely lost and
then all of a sudden he wins the game
which almost happened here but then
again but then in the end it didn't as
the game ended in a draw but they are
really just insane I really thought that
after you see this position that that
after Bishop to c1 you will feel much
better about your own games as well a
super Grand Master rated more than 27 50
missed Queen to d1 check so that's just
that's just incredible
but yeah yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Mohammed Yaseen Christopher Gribben and
Henry Thompson for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing with a few more
games from this rapid and blitz event
checking up on your suggestions such as
this one and of course are continuing
the capablanca saga thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day